The past few years,
Daniel and I have been starting off Mondays with a pull up routine.
So basically, it's 90 pull UPS,
but in three different grips.
So we start off with the traditional wide grip pull up.
We do three sets of 10 with these,
and then we switch to chin UPS.
So chin UPS are my favorite of the grips.
They're the easiest for me.
You can see Daniel helps me a little bit on the way up.
Just a little bit is what I need.
And then he lets go on the way down.
That's perfect. And then he,
of course, is adding a weighted belt.
I think he has 35 pounds on right here,
because he's a beast, and that's just what he does.
And then usually in between sets,
we're doing some sort of, like,
isolated lower body. So I'm doing hip thrust.
I think Daniel is doing calfs today.
And then we just try to recover in between sets.
So this is Daniel's last set of chin UPS.
He no longer has his weighted belts on
because we were getting so tired at this point.
And then even his last few,
he used a chair because it was getting rough.
This is our neutral grip pull UPS.
We did three sets of 10. This is my last set.
I was dying, but I finished.
Daniel threw on his weights again at the very end,
just because he is so hardcore.
But it was Good. It was hard.
We finished strong,
and now I can't move my arms.
I hope you guys all have a great week.